Imagine if all the earth's oxygen
disappeared just for say five seconds.
Would we just hold our breath?
What would happen to the atmosphere?
What would happen and the environment.
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the
world lost oxygen for just five seconds.
Take a nice deep breath.
Feel how satisfying that is,
what you're breathing in his oxygen
and it takes up roughly 21% of our
atmosphere was 78% being nitrogen.
Although it's not the most
abundant gas in our atmosphere,
it is the most important. Without
oxygen, plants, animals, water,
and us humans wouldn't
be where we are today.
Five seconds may not sound like a
whole lot of time to be without oxygen.
Most of us can go at least 30
seconds without taking a breath,
so it would happen too fast
for your body to even notice.
Your breathing would actually remain
normal, but as for everything else,
not so much
in just five seconds,
the earth would look completely different.
Without oxygen,
you can say goodbye to the Hoover dam,
the Pantheon Dome,
and anything else made of concrete.
These structures would instantly collapse.
Oxygen Acts as a special binding
agent to concrete. Without it,
concrete is just dust.
Speaking of buildings,
any untreated metal would
instantly be fused together.
This is because there's a
layer of oxidation on metals
that prevents them from
welding together. Without that layer,
metals would instantly bind to each other.
If you happen to be relaxing at the beach
at the time, expect to severe sunburn.
The ozone layer, our protection against
the sun's UV rays is made of oxygen.
Take away the oxygen and the earth
would become extremely dangerous.
There would be nothing protecting
us from the sun's UV rays.
In addition to a sunburn,
our inner ear would explode.
Losing oxygen means losing 21% of our
air pressure. A change in air pressure.
That drastic is equivalent to being at
sea level and dropping down 2000 meters
instantly. Our ears wouldn't have enough
time to adapt. Having a good time yet,
well, don't expect it to last long
without oxygen. There's no fire.
The combustion process in vehicles
wouldn't be able to occur.
Any mode of transport that isn't
electric will automatically fail.
Planes will fall from the sky and
millions of cars will be stopped in their
tracks. The Sky would be completely
dark before it hits the Earth.
Light from the sun,
bounces off multiple particles in the
air without oxygen in the atmosphere.
There are less things to bounce off
and the sky will appear dark. Oh yeah.
And while all this is happening, the
Earth's crust would completely crumble.
That's because Earth's crust
is made up of 45% oxygen.
The crust would crumble and continue
to crumble until there's nothing left
sending you and everyone on the planet
into a free fall. Sound like fun.
Probably not.
But luckily you can take a deep breath
of 21% oxygen knowing this will never
happen. For more things that are fun to
speculate on. Keep checking back with what
the sky would be completely dark before
it hits the Earth light from the sun,
bounces off multiple particles in the
air without oxygen in the atmosphere.
There are less things to bounce off
and the sky will appear dark. Oh yeah.
And while all this is happening, the
Earth's crust would completely crumble.
That's because Earth's crust
is made up of 45% oxygen.
The Cross would crumble and continue
to crumble until there's nothing left
sending you and everyone on the planet
into a free fall. Sound like fun.
Probably not,
but luckily you can take a deep breath
of 21% oxygen knowing this will never
happen for more things that
are fun to speculate on.
Keep checking back with what if.